to many nikola tesla was a genius
unappreciated in his own time born in
the austrian empire in 1856
the serbian american inventor was
arguably one of the most brilliant minds
of his day and yet tesla never reached
the level of fame and acclaim that he
perhaps deserved for those of you who
are unfamiliar with his work nikola
tesla was a mechanical and electrical
engineer best known for his
contributions to the designs for what
would become the modern alternating
current electricity supply system or ac
it was tesla's hope that he could patent
and sell his inventions that the
creations and advancements he made would
help to improve the lives of everyday
people unfortunately due to the ruthless
and callous business practices of his
rival thomas edison much of nikola
tesla's work faded into obscurity after
his death in 1943
however what if one of his inventions
was not only a success but proved so
deadly in its intended function that it
had to be contained and who better to
keep something like that secure than the
experts in anomalous entities objects
and technology the scp foundation meet
the teleforce one of the surviving
inventions of nikola tesla's legacy
better known to our friends at the
foundation as scp-2700
while most information about various
anomalies is kept secret by the
foundation through the use of memory
altering drugs called amnestics
scp-2700 may be one of the few anomalies
that the public is aware of or at least
they might be aware of the proposed
concept of the teleforce tesla himself
described the invention as a type of
weapon that would fire pellets or rounds
of material however rather than acting
like a conventional firearm the
teleforce would launch these projectiles
at high velocity from inside a vacuum
chamber using electrostatic repulsion to
fire these rounds at the intended target
this probably sounded like a weapon
pulled straight from early works of
science fiction but nikola tesla claimed
that it was an idea that came to him
after he studied the van de graaff
generator it was tesla's hope that his
teleforce could be used as a defensive
weapon that could either be deployed
against enemy infantry on ground level
or even be fired at aircraft with enough
power to bring them down however word of
this invention soon got out to the
public in 1934 a number of new york
newspapers referred to the teleforce
using the fear-mongering descriptions of
a death ray whether this was just a
misunderstanding or done to incite
mistrust in tesla and his work it forced
the inventor to address the matter
publicly saying this invention of mine
does not contemplate the use of any
so-called death rays rays are not
applicable because they cannot be
produced in requisite quantities and
diminish rapidly in intensity with
distance all the energy of new york city
transferred into rays and projected 20
miles could not kill a human being
because according to a well-known law of
physics it would disperse to such an
extent as to be ineffectual my apparatus
projects particles as for the device
itself while the scp foundation was able
to uncover a seemingly perfected version
of the teleforce in 1946
three years after nikola tesla's death
found in an abandoned research facility
believed to have been used by tesla
himself
scp-2700 seemed to be the weapon that
the serbian inventor had described it
was only when the scp foundation began
to take a closer look at the device that
their researchers realized something
scp-2700 could be even more dangerous
than tesla had intended the teleforce to
be in his original designs for the
weapon the device itself is made from
three main components first is the
interface designated scp-2700-1
this is a metal console complete with a
qwerty keyboard and a display screen
along with a number of buttons switches
dials and levers each responsible for
controlling a key aspect of scp-2700
2700-1 features a command-based
operating system with any command typed
on the keyboard appearing on screen in
green block text the foundation is still
baffled as to how an engineer like tesla
even one as gifted as he was able to
create an operating system like this
with the limitations of technology
during the early 1940s a network of
conductive copper wiring then connects
the
scp-2700-1 control console to the other
two components of scp-2700
appropriately known as scp-2700-2
and
scp-2700-3 foundation researchers tasked
with examining and understanding the
teleforce believe the
scp-2700-2 part of the device to be a
particle accelerator now it's hard to go
into exactly how particle accelerators
work in this video but we'll do our best
to keep it short and simple like the
name suggests a particle accelerator's
job is to increase the speed of
subatomic particles like protons or
electrons basically particle
accelerators create a beam of these
particles that have been charged to hold
extremely high amounts of energy and
these charged particle beams are often
useful for a number of different
scientific research methods that's what
the big particle accelerator up at cern
is used for this one
scp-2700-2 on the other hand is
well it's not for research per se it's
held securely in a lead line tungsten
chamber in the shape of a cylinder
although it contains all the parts you'd
expect to find in a modern day particle
accelerator
scp-2700-2 is a lot smaller at just 7.35
meters long
then we get to scp-2700-3
the core of the teleforce also composed
of lead line tungsten it is a spherical
frame with an apparatus inside visible
through a silica glass porthole on one
side within this outer sphere is another
smaller sphere frame that was built
using an unidentified material according
to notes that the foundation has
recovered tesla himself wrote that this
space inside the sphere is held in a
perpetual vacuum state but what is
perhaps most interesting and concerning
about scp-2700-3
isn't the metal frame itself but rather
what is held inside of it lowing at the
center is the fourth and final component
of teleforce known only as
scp-2700 omega this as far as the best
minds of the scp foundation can tell is
the power source of the weapon it is an
anomaly in and of itself a phenomenon of
energy that does not behave within the
normal laws of physics specifically
scp-27
omega directly contradicts what is known
as entropy due to these abnormal
properties the space within
scp-2700-3 containing
scp-2700 omega does not obey standard
rules of time the flow of time within
the power sources chamber seems to be
reversed somehow however researchers
have noted that the frame and inner
sphere of
scp-2700-3 that surround
scp-2700 omega seem to be unaffected by
these anomalous effects it is because of
this power source that
scp-2700 is even more dangerous than
nikola tesla would have ever intended
never mind the fact that the telforce
weapon was designed to fire supercharged
high-velocity rounds at a target the
sole component powering it could prove
to be devastatingly destructive itself
if it ever broke out from within its
frame according to predictions and
calculations made by the scp
foundation's top scientific researchers
if
scp-2700 omega was ever to be released
or accidentally break free from the
scp-2700-3
apparatus that contains it then the
results would be catastrophic the power
source's anomalous properties resisting
the laws of physics and time themselves
would cause a massive chain reaction the
rest of the universe would be converted
to the same inverted state of entropy
that scp-2700
omega exists in which would ultimately
lead to a yk-class entropic annihilation
event the whole universe as we know it
would be pulled inwards creating an
infinitely energetic singularity in
short it would be the big bang but in
reverse with all of creation pulled
inside out the worst part of all this
according to the readouts on
scp-2700-1's display monitor the
teleforce has been armed counting down
the weapon is scheduled to activate in
the year 2234
exactly 300 years after being armed most
likely by tesla himself if the device
was to ever fully activate
scp-2700 omega would be breached and the
entire universe could be unraveled and
sucked into a singularity the only hope
the scp foundation has of preventing
this destruction is to destroy or
contain
scp-2700 within another scp the o5
council are still searching for a
suitable candidate should the worst come
to pass for now personnel have been
instructed to avoid tampering with the
teleforce in any way shape or form
should
scp-2700 omega show any change in its
behavior then let's just hope that the
overseer council is able to produce an
anomaly capable of neutralizing it but
there's still one other big question
that needs answering namely how on earth
did nikola tesla a scientist limited by
the technology of his time create a
power source like
scp-2700 omega something with the
capability to unravel the entire
universe if it ever breached its
containment while the man himself may
have given us the answers the scp
archives file on
scp-2700 concludes with an extract of a
log that nikola tesla kept during the
last decade of his life as we mentioned
before tesla was not exactly a success
in his own time he chose to keep trying
to produce his inventions despite
driving himself towards financial ruin
he was the vincent van gogh of science
depression took a hold of the inventor
in his later years until one day he was
approached by a mysterious figure this
man as it turns out was a traveler from
another universe and brought tesla with
him to this alternate reality in his
logbook nicola lamented over how
discontent he was with his life in our
universe and how transcendentally
beautiful it was in this new one while
there tesla worked with a group of
fellow scientists all brought to that
universe by the same traveler with the
goal of creating a source of perpetual
energy this power source was intended to
break the known laws of thermodynamics
and it seemed that
scp-2700 omega itself was the outcome of
these scientific minds coming together
by combining two substances from two
universes with completely different laws
of physics to our own tesla and the
others created the power source they had
dreamed of but things quickly started to
go wrong tesla realized that the core
later known as
scp-2700 omega was somehow moving
backwards in time as he tried to correct
it he realized the device had been
locked and that someone had armed it why
the traveler revealed that this was his
plan all along
to create something capable of
destroying this universe it turned out
the alternate universe he had brought
tesla to was not the traveler's home
rather a different place he wished to
destroy with the singularity that
scp-2700
omega would cause the traveler vanished
to his true home leaving nikola tesla
alone with scp-2700
saddened to think his invention would
destroy this new universe which he found
to be profoundly beautiful he made a
truly unexpected decision he returned
home and in his sadness thought it would
be better if the device he'd helped
create brought about the end of our
universe
scp-2700 is now a ticking time bomb
destined to wipe out our entire reality
unless the device can be disarmed or
otherwise neutralized all this set in
motion by a scientist long dead who
submitted all of us as an unwilling
sacrifice for a universe we'd never know
or perhaps this was done as an act of
revenge for his own lack of success and
appreciation in life one final act to
make sure that if he wasn't remembered
no one else would be either or maybe
just maybe tesla saw past the slights
maybe he had so much faith in humanity
that he trusted we would one day be able
to figure out how to stop
scp-2700 omega and both universes and
the process no matter his reasoning all
we can do now is place our hope in the
scp foundation's top minds to find a
solution but the clock is ticking now go
check out
scp-1461 house of the worm and
scp-1765 sisters for terrifying tales of
anomalous science gone wrong